Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, Big Channel
and Life Updates happening that I wanted to
tell you all about.
Every thing is good news don’t worry.
It’s just that because I already do so many
videos, it’s hard to fit extra stuff in
that’s important but doesn’t have anything
to do with dragons, zombies, space ships or
time lords.
So here’s what I’m going to do, first
I’ll let you know about the biggest changes
that have happened or are going to happen.
Everything from the videos I’m doing to
physical changes to the Youtube platform.
Second, I’ll let you know what’s going
on in real life behind the scenes here.
I’m going to be making some big life changes
through the course of the year that will just
make it easier to do what I love, which is
making youtube videos and hanging out with
you guys.
Then, because I totally don’t do it enough
I’m going to let you know which other youtubers
I really like to watch.
And other youtube related happenings that
I’m really excited about.
I feel like at some point I’ll have to create
a channel just for vlogging, but until my
dream of becoming a space pirate comes true
I think it’s okay to just squeeze it in
on Emergency Awesome every once and a while.
So here we go, starting with new videos I’m
working on:
This weekend is the Walking Dead finale.
If you’re not quite caught up, I recommend
you binge watch netflix, they have everything
up to season 4, AMC is also running a marathon
of season 4 episodes to fill the gap.
Everything else I do, Doctor Who, Arrow, Marvel,
Agents of SHIELD, and so on is staying the
same.
No changes there.
But Game of Thrones is coming back April 6th,
so what’s going to happen is those videos
will take the place of the Walking Dead videos
I would normally be doing.
I’ll still do bonus videos for Walking Dead
just like I do for other favorite shows in
the off season.
If there’s any particular type of bonus
videos you want to see, just leave me suggestions
in the comments.
In addition to swapping Walking Dead Sundays
with Game of Thrones, my weekly giveaway will
be happening every week for each episode.
There are 10 episodes, so that’s 10 more
weeks of giveaway.
So now let’s talk about big Youtube changes
that have happened.
Youtube itself has changed a lot about the
way it shows you guys new videos I’ve posted.
Most of the time it works okay, but sometimes
it’s an epic fail.
So here are a couple of things you can do
just to make sure you don’t miss out on
giveaways or new videos.
There are two different layouts you guys might
be seeing, but youtube calls this “The Guide”.
This is where most of you see my new videos
show up.
Go to the ‘My Subscriptions Tab’, which,
depending on your layout is over here on the
left hand side.
Or up at the top of your home page.
Inside your subscriptions page you can just
mouse over one of my videos and select “Get
An Email” for each upload from Emergency
Awesome.
I typically post about 10 videos a week, so
this is the only way to guarantee you don’t
miss stuff.
I know a lot of you are international, so
there’s a huge time zone difference and
sometimes I end up posting videos while you’re
asleep.
As much as youtube does weird things to change
how everything looks.
This is one feature that is amazing, but that
a lot of you might not know about.
So for example, I have about 30 youtubers
I subscribe to, but I want to get alerts for
my favorites like vlogbrothers and DFTBA stuff.
So for them I enable this email alert and
for everyone else, I just leave it on the
default.
There’s also the tried and true refresh
method, where I just sit on their youtube
pages and refresh until they post new videos.
I know some of you like to do this too.
It’s an oldie but a goodie.
Personally I would recommend just enabling
email alerts and saving yourself the trouble.
If you’re not a big email person, or you
just want to talk to me off youtube there’s
social.
I’m most active on Twitter, Facebook, Tumblr,
Instagram and Google plus.
Here’s the links for all those accounts.
There’s also links at the top of my channel
page here.
I wasn’t able to fit my entire name on twitter,
so that’s a little different.
But for the most part, I’m Emergency Awesome
everywhere.
So if it’s the middle of the day and you
just want to say hi, you can always tweet
at me or post on my facebook page.
I read all the youtube comments, but here’s
where I need to mention Google Plus, because
it does affect which comments I see at the
top.
If you haven’t heard about it, Google Plus
created this thing on youtube called Top Fans.
It’s just a way to benefit the people who
engage with me the most on my videos.
In the future, I’m going to do some exclusive
giveaways, google hangouts and there might
be free t-shirts at some point.
The easiest way to jump to the top of that
list is to follow me on google plus.
I do like Google Plus, but it’s mostly helpful
for managing comments.
Also, because of google plus, now if you want
to make sure I see you’re comment.
All you have to do is add the “+” symbol
in front of my name and it will ‘mention’
me.
It’s like mentioning someone on twitter.
I still read all the comments on videos no
matter what, but when you add that + it send
it directly to my gmail.
So that pretty much covers all the big youtube
changes.
Like I said, it breaks a lot, but it’s a
free platform and all my social accounts allow
me to talk with you guys when youtube does
fail.
Here’s what’s going on behind the scenes
in real life.
I am still working at my full time job, I
may be turning full time creator by the end
of the year.
Which is my dream.
I’ll definitely let you guys know if that
happens sooner.
Because we will be poppin’ bottles.
In the short term, I am still looking for
a new apartment.
I have to reloacte the TARDIS to somewhere
a little bigger just to make it easier to
shoot youtube videos.
Probably sometime this summer before Comic
Con.
I’ll be sure to do a room tour once I get
everything set up.
I’ll be getting some extra gear that will
make it easier to do live streams, but there’s
a lot of technical stuff involved.
So for example during the fall you might see
me do Live Doctor Who and Walking Dead videos.
Which I’m excited to try.
So if you have any questions about videos
coming up that I’ll be doing or just stuff
that’s going on in my life, just write it
in the comments.
Or feel free to high five me on twitter.
If you’re just now finding me and you have
no idea what’s going on, be sure to Subscribe
below to get all my stuff.
There are dragons coming next week.
Here’s a couple other youtube things that
are happening in the near future that I’m
really excited about including conventions.
I’ll be at Wondercon at the end of April,
I’ll be at VidCon at the end of June and
I’ll be at Comic Con at the end of July.
I might also be doing a panel at Comic Con,
but I don’t know what’s happening, so
I’ll post updates when it’s all figured
out.
Here are a few youtubers that you may already
know about, but that I spend a lot of time
watching when I’m not making my own videos.
First is Hank and John Green.
Most of the time I watch their vlogbrothers
videos.
But I also subscribe to all their DFTBA channels
like scishow and the new scishowspace.
They’re going to be doing cool space stuff
there.
Then there’s Vsauce with Michael, I actually
used to work with him on Barely Political
videos in the early days of youtube.
And for video game stuff I’m a big fan of
Pewds like the rest of the world and smaller
creators like Dodger on her Dexterity Bonus
and PressHeart channels.
So remember, Walking Dead finale sunday.
Click here for my final predictions and click
here to start getting ready for Game of Thrones.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!